this morning the president of france
revealed that he has
the coronavirus emmanuel macron attended
a european summit meeting less than a
week ago
now other leaders who recently met with
macron are going into quarantine
roxanna saberi has more from london
days after french president emmanuel
macron greeted european leaders
he's tested positive for covet 19. the
president's palace says he has symptoms
but didn't specify what they are and
that he'll keep working while isolating
for seven days
now a series of officials he met
including spanish prime minister pedro
sanchez
will do the same the news comes as
france this week
eased its national coronavirus lockdown
and tightened an overnight curfew
the virus is still raging there and
across europe
including in sweden where king carl
gustav is now acknowledging that his
country has failed to protect the
elderly in nursing homes
from the pandemic sweden has long stood
out for shunning national lockdowns
and relying on people to social distance
themselves
in germany which closed schools and
non-essential shops yesterday
and in london which is now under tighter
restrictions
officials are calling for this year's
christmas celebrations
to be much more subdued we should
exercise
extreme caution in the way we
celebrate christmas we can celebrate it
sensibly but we have to be extremely
cautious
in the way and we've just learned that
portuguese prime minister antonia costa
is also now self-isolating he met with
macron
yesterday tony now what is immune
roxanna savari in london for us roxanna
thank you very much